when I met her I said to you that I like
her
but I also told you she doesn't like me
back
when I find that out I just move on
she's my friend that's how I see her now
I don't understand because I didn't work
with her you may have sex we didn't we
never we never even kissed but sex was
not the issue for me you want to ignore
the emotional cheating and just focus on
the fact that it was more emotional
cheating what emotional cheating you
both fully engaged you liked her right
but it didn't move forward because she
wouldn't allow it to if she liked you
back it would have went further it did
not move forward because of me and your
feelings for me see what I'm saying you
weren't ready to choose me you were
going to choose her she just didn't
choose you back
that's what I'm trying to get you to
understand how that feels to me in 2020
when I met her you and I we haven't even
met in person at that time like I was
not sure that this was gonna work the
distance everything was against us we're
not in the same place that we were at
that time okay right now we are about to
get married and I'm Gonna Learn and
Michelle is still an issue the bottom
line is I was okay with meeting Michelle
and if she's cool that's fine if not and
I don't feel comfortable then she just
won't be coming to the wedding
I mean that's
that's pretty nice that's immature
like it's that girl needs to wait for
you to approve if she goes or not that
was our agreement what are you talking
about I don't I don't want that
agreement
I already invite her
I'm not understanding where the
confusion is the plan was that I would
meet her
he and I were discuss and I would let
him know whether I was okay with her
coming to the wedding but now he's
breaking the agreement that we made I'm
respecting you why you're not respecting
me
[Music]
thank you